oder mein lukas name und wir spielen
hallo mein lukas name ok alles klar
mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu den dünnsten addario
fetzen videochat mal wieder ich bin mal
wieder durch die weiten des internets
gewandert und habe dabei gesehen dass es
eine wahl gibt die punkte und das ist
das wo wir uns gerade befinden nämlich
gegen eine komische wir spielen das
einfach mal einfach luca erpresserische
start und wir sind nämlich hier dieser
typ kaputt wer als bottrop
wir sind dieser typ hier und was ist
wenn die alte als wenn mir einfach alles
schaden zufügt sind die denn sehen denn
dumm man muss allen sachen ausweichen
kann mit der sg steuern und mit der maus
seht ihr schon kann ich hier
beispielsweise da mal hin schießen und
das ist ein gegner von mir glaube ich
und wenn ich den abschießen dann bekomme
bekommt der schaden und ist es überhaupt
ein gegner von mir und muss den ganzen
city ausweichen und ich muss sagen sie
ihnen hier treffen muss ihn töten und
dann seht ihr schon dass unten mein
level irgendwie vorangeht mit der goa
mein gott okay du stehst erstmal als
erstes der war aber auch richtig doof
ist problem ist ich kann das ganze
irgendwie bin zu dumm das ganze auf hd
dings einzustellen die grafik ist zwar
gut aber es sind wahrscheinlich ein paar
sachen abgemacht guck mal was kann ich
denn hier machen
ich kann die scheiße mich hochpumpen
oder wahrscheinlich das scoreboard nicht
so ganz eingeblendet oder ich habe meine
liebe sport level frühjahr okay das ist
neues netz hat irgendwie so ein
zwischenspeicher chip dings untätiger
ich träume und dieser spaß
bastad schießt mich direkt ab oder was
wieso schieße ich überhaupt so langsam
meine fresse lasst mich doch in ruhe man
es ist ein scheiß das ist wirklich so
der dümmste fake von mario ich weiß sie
soll es wirklich ein fake darstellen
oder nicht also mir wird gesagt luca die
bio dass das hier was ist das ist
grafikfehler leicht gewollt und es tut
auch faktisch okay der ist genauso muss
wie ich das heißt auch mein gott wie so
ist er denn so sachen die denn alle so
so krasse sachen die sehen alle echt
heftig aus wenn nicht theoretisch
hierhin schießt um das ding verfolge
tatsache man kann sich selbst
abschließen ich glaube ich schieß jetzt
einfach mal so viel von diesem kleinen
teil hier ab so dass ich einfach einen
hohen level erreicht warum bin ich denn
schon wieder tot meine verfügten plakate
ding und bin ich bin jetzt im aus ich
mach mal politik manchmal ein bisschen
mehr kann in den höher machen ich glaube
was ich erreiche ja genau seht ihr schon
kann ich jetzt hier platz bieten noch
ein hör machen jetzt kann ich hier
wieder die abschießen jetzt kann ich
nämlich wieder bullitt um 1 höher machen
ich wette wenn man den anderen tötet
bekommt man dann einfach noch mehr level
zuwachs und ich töte halt gerade nur die
teile die hier halt herumschweben
deswegen bekomme ich halt nicht so viele
levels was passiert wenn ich ihn getötet
da bekomme ich doch locker weil er so
fährt ist richtig viel oder warten wir
warten mal ganz kurz ab ich schieß ihn
ab und er ist jetzt tot und ich war
willen nein
ja ich weiß eine typische dümmste agrio
fake war ich mir wirklich gedacht habe
okay gut was ist da das ist macht das
überhaupt sind das spiel aber es macht
mir ultra viel spaß da komme ich kann
die leute hier abknallen und das ist der
sinn des spiels
es ist nicht spitzen idee gewesen fern
entwickler ich finde es macht spaß ich
weiß nicht ob es spaß macht zuzuschauen
aber für mich macht cultra viel spaß das
ganze so trotteln freunde schaut mich
mal an ich kann in beide richtungen
schießen und das ultraschnell ich bin im
himmel ich stell mich jetzt einfach
zwischen die beiden und kann die beiden
dann halt immer dauerhaft penetrieren
wien ist da denn ich bin schon level 18
verfickte henne oh mein gott nein nein
nein nein nein
ich habe mich jetzt einfach mal ich töte
euch genannt und sporne natürlich direkt
diese überall schießen leute rum das ist
aber finde ich eine coole idee dass man
dann quasi wieder bei level 10 anfangen
kann manchmal jetzt helfen weil ich habe
maximal herausragend alter schwede ist
hier ein tolles spiel oder muss ich ihr
nur dieser kacke wieder ausweichen die
auf mich geschossen wird diese teile die
man quasi abschießt sowie bei addario
dieses kleine fressen diese kleinen
teile die halt quasi überall rumliegen
findet doch ehrlich gesagt gut was ich
mir wieder für prioritäten bei der
punkte wahl gegeben habe ich hab nämlich
health management komplett voll und
maxximum herd und ehemaliger was das
paar das gerade theoretisch kann man die
ganze zeit damit verbringen einfach
dieses ding da ab zu ballern und gott
diese verfolgen die mich denn und
wechselt er den skis andere ab die in
deiner ligaspielen aber nicht mich kein
hobby so viel was bist du denn ich bin
jetzt eine maschinen dann und habe jetzt
mal gedacht ok maschinen ganz vielleicht
macht es sinn
ich weiß nicht was ich jetzt mehr machen
kann ich glaube ich kann dir teile
einfach schneller raus hauen ist ja
schon mal ganz schön alter schwede hier
ist einfach 18 hat es wieder der
komische fritze da in der fresse ich
könnte ich bin jetzt wieder allein
unterwegs schießt jedoch die timer
abschießt da noch die kleine abschießen
jason lee kämpfen schießen
ich hab nur augen für den um ein gott
freundlich weiche hier gerade nur leuten
was wir irgendwie ist ein kleiner knips
lass mich in ruhe
luca war ich aus oh mein gott alter
schwede ist das schwer
man guckt sich das ganze an und denkt
sich so ja okay da kann er hier
ausweichen da ausweichen das spiel macht
echt spaß ich bin in der ruder bei 20
minuten das ist das ist so weit komme
ich nur noch 111 mensch vielleicht ultra
war mein gott ok just the way you mind
alter schwede
dpa so lasst mich in ruhe ich war echt
weit ich war
nicht weit an dieser stelle würde ich
das ganze video allerdings auch beenden
ich weiß im titel steht dümmste agrio
fake das ist einfach weil ich das zu
beginn dachte und auch zu beginn des
videos dachte habe mich darauf weil die
ganze zeit bezogen aber jetzt gerade
muss ich sagen es macht mir spaß
das spiel ist echt nice wenn ihr davon
einen zweiten teil sehen wo es
eigentlich verpackung fahren
wenn ihr im zweiten teil davon sehen
wollt was ich sehr hoffe weil es mir
sehr viel spaß macht dann schreibt das
einfach mal die kommentare last eine
bewertung da schaffen wir 50.000 live
ich weiß nicht dass viel zu viel
schaffen wir das halt die coolen oder
nicht wir sehen uns dann im nächsten
teil wieder oder auch wenn ihr das nicht
wollt oder nicht was hat das von
synergien